elle est un peu apprivoisée et on l'a
laissé à l'état sauvage des fois elle
s'en va elle revient elle voilà les
animaux de la ferme se laissent caresser
pour ses visiteurs handicapés et leurs
accompagnateurs de région parisienne le
dépaysement est total il a 3 ans il
s'appelle alpha donc un petit poney
shetland
on peut voir les traditionnelles poule
des canards chèvres Anne poney sur cette
exploitation on cultive des céréales
orge blé colza et pois l'idée de
travailler autour du grain du gras qu'on
produit sur l'exploitation
essentiellement le grain de blé bien sûr
ce qu'on est quand même principalement
en culture de blé mais aussi sur tout le
reste
les les animaux le pain
l'oeuf tout tout ce qu'on peut faire
avec tout ça les visites s'inscrivent
dans le cadre du réseau Bienvenue à la
ferme pour des visites de ferme on a
quand même pas mal de gens qui sont
intéressés pour savoir à quoi ça
ressemble l'agriculture d'aujourd'hui et
puis et puis comment on produit
finalement ce qui consomme quoi donc ça
les intéresse beaucoup à devenir dans
les fermes donc on a on a de tout dans
les exploitations on a des fermes
céréalières on a des fermes d'élevage
voilà on a tous types de production
après plein de prestations différentes
qui sont proposées de l'hébergement de
la des repas des produits à vendre enfin
on a un peu de tout
depuis deux ans Martine et Bertrand
propose un hébergement en yourte 70
euros la nuitée pour deux personnes
petit déjeuner compris une belle façon
de prolonger le dépaysement de partager
des valeurs d'authenticité et d'exigence
de qualité en France plus de 8000
agriculteurs font partie du réseau
Bienvenue à la ferme